hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
I'm a property investor and I decided to
document the whole eh-2-zed step by step
process of buying a property and then
adding value and refinancing it and
pulling out your money I've been doing
this for 10 years and this is how you
can take a small little pot of money and
you can continue to recycle it recycle
it buying more and more houses over and
over again for free so enjoy the journey
I've documented everything it's coming
baby
so I actually found this property on
Rightmove and it was on the market for
70,000 pounds now because he needs a lot
of work chances are I'll be able to put
in a very cheeky offer and it may just
well be accepted so I offered to buy the
property for sixty four thousand pounds
and they said yes which was a little bit
of a bargain considering that there's
others selling in the street that are
exactly the same but in good condition
for anywhere from 85 rot up to past
ninety thousand pounds I know the
Darlington is a very cheap area but the
rents are reasonably high so it fits in
with my buy low rent high formula the
floor plan looks pretty decent
it's a spacious property but it is an
absolute mess so the crazy thing is that
house they're number 55 which is in the
same street 55 sold for a hundred
thousand pounds in January 2018 this one
this small little red one number 59 sold
for eighty six thousand pounds
April last year and then right there
which has the sold sign outside sold
last week for sixty four thousand pounds
so by the time I've done it up and
refurbed it there's no reason why it
shouldn't be worth at least 90 thousand
pounds properties are renting out in
this street for between five hundred and
five seventy five so so my estimation is
that my property will rent out anywhere
between five and five fifty per month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning good trip Nicholas bacon
how coming out
hello Nicola my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
just calling I'm just on my way to pick
up the keys to anything awesome strength
I'll make sure that I do have the keys
ready for a mule oh that's fantastic I'm
really great I'll be there probably in
about 10 minutes or so hope that's okay
and yeah yes that's fantastic so really
excited to meet you guys and I'm really
grateful again so I'll see you real
short like you know we forgot a gift
it's always a good idea to get a gift
I might knipfing to this petrol station
to get card or something and some
flowers perfect
you know you've said that the keys are
in the property so if we let ourselves
in the back and then we'll get probably
a big bunch somewhere so are you honest
those keys so my plan was to buy the
property renovate it and then refinance
it we call this a buy refurbish
refinance which means that when you put
your money in you then later pull it out
and you keep hold of a property and you
rent it out and just enjoy the monthly
passive income
[Applause]
doesn't look bad actually it's better
than the pictures yeah I can see why the
quote was well just dated isn't that
cosmetic surprisingly good it looked
terrible all the pictures the pictures
made it look so bad we can get this done
in two weeks man what color what color
with the Platinum I don't know but this
is I just paid you because of the light
yes
or do you think of the boil it's a back
seat which is a good mate
it's got good pressure on it so it's
working well yeah it's not losing
pressure
it is commonly boiler yeah as long as
they're given a certificate the way to
find out how good the board the boiler
is is to see how that the water is
already look Chris that's already hot I
took about five or ten seconds to have
it what so it's obviously the boiler is
not bad I've got some damp under there
but don't dump down there is normal
isn't it because they'll a bit of
washing machine there yeah it could just
be off a washing machine bleep yeah
it's not like you've got dumped on the
walls and stuff just don't hear whether
what you see yes it's low level yeah
it's just ashamed of it to not do it
properly and I think that we want the
tenants to move in and we want to get
top red bottom to stay what the value is
go into the kitchen kitchen is what
sells the house because when you come
into you know that property that we'll
just rent it out for four five hundred
pound Chris that was a too bad
guess what the front cover was on the
advert the freaking kitchen because the
kitchen is what sells the house so we
could cheapskate it and we could just
paint this thought why not just it's not
going to cost a lot money darling and
everything's so cheap a new kitchen and
new tiles they said four thousand nine
hundred we say six thousand if we do it
really well that way we'll get better
terms will get a better valuation
because you've got the value of work
they'll talk if he comes in if he comes
in and we
we've watched a hoedown fine you know
what the others that were selling for a
hundred in the street they know me sir
so we want to do but I don't want it
nice you could make a really nice
electric fire in there for about hundred
quid Erica's the windows are beautiful
double glazed good windows a like the
wooden a lot of the wooden base it just
needs me he just needs carpets in the
paint really it is an old style fuse box
which again is not great but they've put
these things we'll just stop it tripping
these little traps so for a simple that
what do you think which I think will be
fine I think it's fine somebody's
already else is going to do yeah that's
good
that's a big bathroom and you can do
destructive as I put this on the quote
already wrong now but that's gonna cost
peanuts right yeah you're looking at
about 300 pounds yeah
oh is it [ __ ] out war and it's not a lot
of money bringing shower again
now you get one put under poems I live
nowadays shower
yeah and that's coming out really hot
yeah that's it knee taps new shower but
just the actual shower bit not all this
this is okay and something cost a lot of
money at all
exact same story isn't it just again you
didn't get me fine I'm over this one
think you'll be fine yeah it's good
wallpaper it just it's just a horrible
cut I think these are fine these two
stabbed just carpet which will be the
hundred pound and then paint which Ben
Darlington is also third row it's a
small room but is a child's room isn't
it on office it looks like it's been
really well looked after by an old
couple they've now moved on and it's
just not being redecorated forty years
so you see this is where the goddamn
coming in it's making it peel and cut
the paper builders the old folks so this
is the outside of the property we've
just bought it for sixty four thousand
pounds and with my property agent and
what do you think of the price that we
got it for all right and you've got the
property at steel and you know with the
local comparables with what's being sold
in the market nearby and the properties
are going for in that yeah you know you
can see in the street you know that one
over there told for ninety thousand just
the one a few doors down sort 487 agent
alive somewhat like that
so 64,000 the truth you see the true
potential once it's been fully renovated
how much do you think it'll rent out for
once it's fully renovated you look at
around 550 - 575 from my always thinking
about 500 but but there's a two-bed in
the same street that's rent in four four
nine five so this is a three bed if it's
done right yeah see the good thing is is
if you renovate the property and Ten
Eyck set they don't mind came further 25
the market is pretty buoyant yes yes yes
sir
especially amenities yeah it's a
fantastic area crying you made a really
good investment I know you know a lot of
the value was out here as well
yes my nan Connells I know Eve yeah
countrywide I've got all the cities I'm
in contact with them and that's great
yeah thanks bro thank you awesome ninety
thousand that's that's what we're hoping
for
all right I think I can hear the
seagulls does that make sense anyway so
far first impressions is a really
important thing because the valuer
before we even walked into the house is
gonna have a figure in his mind I like
what they've done on the outside they've
painted it clearly before it was that
horrible dirty stone so that's good but
I'm not particularly impressed of all
the mess that was left outside all these
paintbrushes and Fanta cans I mean come
on and when you paying Builders to do
the work on your property you don't
expect them to leave a mess like this
but anyway let's hope that inside is a
bit better and I'm feeling impressed on
the inside okay pretty tidy really I
knew I mean fire which is a lot better
wouldn't be my choice of carpet but
looks nice that's just fine what I
wouldn't have put blinds I would have
put curtains but again kind of
preference yeah like it ah this is nice
I'm really pleased at this I'm so glad
that we work with a whole new kitchen
what can I say I've lived here myself
just fantastic the flooring is great
absolutely spot-on I love the kitchen
also I can tell there's a kitchen that's
been built to last as well I like this a
lot it's just so much fresher now I said
look at the bathroom oh man
wasn't wasn't the shower here before
they didn't old the old shower was here
we were thinking about fixing it and
then I just said look just gonna hold
you bathroom another put the top of the
toilet oh this is brilliant spotlight
this is fantastic you know most people
what they're bothered about is having a
good bathroom in a good kitchen and the
bathroom in the kitchen a 10 out of 10
you know it's clean when you don't mind
kissing it it's just fantastic I can't
believe I can't believe that the done
this for 7000 pounds I know initially
they were saying five and a half
thousand but then that was before I said
just do a whole new kitchen homey
bathroom like we've upped a bit we've
put in new things we've put a nice
electric fire downstairs 7,000 pounds
and it's done in two weeks just great
just fun that I know at first when we
first walked in I didn't love the the
color of the carpet but I think it's
kind of grown on me now
especially as I mean upstairs it looks
it looks nice it's all the same it's all
matching it's just great I would live
here pretty much everything that could
possibly have been fixed and done has
been done you know everything has been
done
and it looks great I am really impressed
I think that the rent because it's been
done to a high standard
I think the rent is going to be
significantly higher I mean maybe you
will get five hundred pounds a month I
can't wait to see what the new value is
of this house my guess is the new value
is from memory
under this of an asset I'm gonna be
conservative I'm going to say the value
of this is 85,000 pounds and the rent is
five hundred pounds in which case we'll
go out to pull out all of the money that
we put in including their money for the
refurb which would be absolutely amazing
so fingers crossed I think we need to
get some estate agents some Latin agents
some valuers down to the property
someone to make some calls get some
folks that's the property gets a
professional local opinion the refurb on
the property is fantastic Stu a high
standard throughout and it would attempt
first time a lot of first-time buyers to
look at the property if it was my
property I would actually put it back
onto the market for resale we have a lot
of first-time buyers looking in that
area at the moment the property's done
to a high spec condition ready to move
into so it will probably sell quite
quickly it would probably take well as
quickly as we could we know we would
have people looking ready to view
straight away so we would hope for a
very quick turnaround my name's Michael
I'm a local lettings expert our work for
bridge foods and this is the type of
house that we would want an old books
which we would rent all day long so what
do you think yeah the property is great
obviously refurbished it's a really good
standard kitchen and bathroom a really
modern obviously it'll appeal to a lot
of people and great deck all good
carpets yeah obviously addition of the
conservatory in the box oh yeah Gardens
always a bore no so you've got families
looking and people with kids possibly
pets professional couples are what a bit
of outside space so yep I was born as
definitely so what sort of tenants do
you think would be wanting to move into
this house so very typically for this
type of house I would expect to get a
family as with it being 3-bedroom
and then you've got the addition of the
conservatory to reception rooms and you
would also look to market for
professional couples and possibly
somebody single maybe what's family in
the area but your main target market
it's definitely going to be your family
who want to take advantage of the garden
and a nice kitchen good-size space in
size so be brutally honest with me tell
me about the area is it good area bad
area every such a really gorgeous it's
very popular area and I don't if you
know the names and things it's the
Harrogate Hill area and so you've got
local schools it's always been a popular
area traditionally traditional houses
like new builds further up always really
popular always in demand or get good
area yeah if you were managing this
property then would I ever have to come
to the house or would you literally do
everything we do everything you would
only need to come here unless she
particularly wanted to and office as an
agency we take charge of everything so
we offer fully managed and so you don't
even need to set foot in the house
unless you particular one or two so the
killer question then how much you think
this would rent out for realistically I
think you rent very roughly as I said
the street is quite varied very roughly
and expect to get between five hundred
and five to five and possibly pushed to
550 in a good strong market you'll know
in the first week or so if you're going
to get that figure and if not get the
price down and expect to achieve between
I would say five hundred minimum to
about five to five ish know you yeah the
only thing we're in competition with
this sort of seventy touched houses and
which I'd expect to get that was a
minimum yeah I mean we would guide you
and I'll see if the market changes or
what have you
obviously we change with it I would
expect to get five hundred pounds but
obviously while working as how the
markets performing yeah so if you were
to manage this then what do you charge
to fully manage this so that I wouldn't
need to ever come to the property again
and so we're very proactive agent we did
to get something very fast for an
introduction or any service where we
just find the tenant adult manages
we would charge a flat fee of five
hundred plus part and that's obviously
payable once the tenants moved in always
ruphylin a very lovely yeah for a
standard letting service which is like a
rent collect service or an upgraded to a
fully managed service that would be for
50 plus part as a like initial setup
cost and percentage-wise
10% plus VAT for rent collect at the 11
percent plus faster for a fully managed
service fully manages everything yet
rain collect is basically fully managed
without the maintenance yeah absolutely
yeah yeah yeah we do all that if you
were me would you rent it or would you
sell it I personally would rent it
simply because long term obviously but
again more and every wise and market
wise typically you would rent it faster
than you would sell it obviously you
never know until you actually try but
typically you would rent it a lot faster
so realistically how long do think it
would take before this was completely
rented out how it expects well we would
have to get as soon as he moved in with
about a month to two months maximum so I
would expect in the first week to have a
lot of interest if we didn't we ignore
that the pricing wasn't right or
something wasn't right and then from
that expect to get something within
about three to four weeks hopefully two
months maximum I would say and I know
your sales isn't your department but how
long do you think it might take to sell
this property very difficult sales is a
lot more varied and that is difficult to
say I would expect probably within maybe
about six months or so which seems like
a long time but giving us this market
it's just we're there to go support that
it's a very rough guys it's interesting
that you said you would rent it and
Nicola said she would sell it all right
what why do you think that is
I suppose you once obviously the she
does sales that's what she technically
you would find a tenant faster but
having said that you never know until
you try
so right now I'm standing outside the
property and I do really like this
property now and I'm torn between two
things option number one is I can sell
the property and considering I bought it
for sixty four thousand I've only spent
seven thousand on it it's now worth
close to ninety thousand it would give
me a nice quick chunk of money now which
I can then reinvest with and do what
I want with so that's a good option but
then the other option is I can keep it
and rent it out and if I do that I'm
gonna make a nice recurring passive
income on the property and I'll still be
able to refinance it and get a new
mortgage on the property and pull out
nearly all of my initial money invested
you know I could sell this house but by
the looks of this there's tenants
absolutely desperate to move into
properties like this in this area and I
think I'm gonna affect 500 to 550 all
day long you know people say the
landlords are money-grabbing and screw
over poor tenants but that's actually
not true at all a good investor or
landlord is someone who does their
market research in an area finds out
what tenants are looking for and then
gives it to them you're only going to
make money when you first add value and
this house is beautiful
I'd live in here so I think I'm going to
rent it out refinance it pour as much
money as I can possibly back out of the
property and I don't think I'm ever
gonna need to come to this house ever
again fantastic news the tenants are
moving in next week they're going to be
paying 525 pounds a month all the
references of coming well and Bridgeford
estate agents have sent out the ASD
contract for me to sign so really
pleased about that even better news is
this is my refinance acceptance meaning
that I can pull out get a new mortgage
and pull out all of the money that I put
in initially on a property which means I
have to keep going
buying more houses recycling the same
deposit again and again I hope you
enjoyed watching the journey from start
to finish takes a lot of time to film
these things and document them properly
so if you want to see more please do
drop a comment below smash that like
button and if you're not already
subscribed be sure to subscribe to the
channel and you know what if you want to
do this yourself and you want to learn
about property I've got a two day
property investors crash course and
people all the time we're doing deals
like this one and even better and I'd
like to invite you to come along
absolutely free as my guest on the house
and there's a link below in the
descriptions where you can get yourself
booked on to the property investors
crash course and learn how to do this
yourself
thanks for watching peace out I'll see
you next time
[Music]
welcome mr. Mel has has been really good
we well did everything the buyer
possibly could offer the right price and
completed within a really short
timescale